what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe in your potential and I want
to see it be unleashed into the world to
create something special for you your
family in the world and so to help you
on your journey I started to mentor me
series to try to learn from people who
have done a lot more than us who've
reach for the stars and if we can learn
about their mindset their mentality how
they approach life hopefully some of
that seeps into us to help us become the
best version of ourselves so today we're
gonna learn from Grant Cardone and how
to 10x your life mentor me grant and as
always guys as you're watching if you
hear something that really resonates
with you please leave it down in the
comments below and put it in quotes so
other people can be inspired and when
you write it down it's much more likely
to stick with yourself as well
enjoy
[Music]
you
and basically 2009-2010 and eleven
really kind of showed me oh man a lot of
my thinking was broken Bryan it was like
I wasn't thinking big enough and the 10x
rule is really about how could somebody
take where they're at if they're making
if they're making twenty nine dollars an
hour or $15 an hour or $8 an hour or
you're you're you you're not even
horrible right now by the way I've been
in every one of those situations or
maybe you're making maybe you're making
$150,000 a year now so from nothing to
150 grand or a million how would you
take in 10x
all that activity and then while you're
doing that also 10x your marriage 10x
the kids 10x your time off how could I
have everything because frankly I get
sick of hearing about people talk to me
about part time doing something part
time a guy pitched me other day hey man
if I could just get your help part time
I might do it I don't do anything part
time part-time to me is like communism
and the devil okay I'm an all in all in
guy I you know it's never paid off for
me to be a be a dilettante or a
spectator or kind of halfway in it's you
know I've only got to pay off when I was
all in all the time and so the 10x rule
was really about how could I'm literally
expand my thinking and also 10x the the
activity necessary with the limited time
that we all have how could I 10x my
activity be more places be more social
have more family having well I know it
sounds impossible yeah but the reason
it's impossible is because everybody's
thinking they need to balance life but
life is too long for most people most
people end up at the end of their
lifetime the last the golden years with
no gold right I got too much time and no
money and and this is happening in the
wealthiest country on planet Earth is
America where freedom is the choice you
know courage
our battle cry and we have a middle
class a big giant middle class in
America made about 250 million people
they can't even pay their bills today
it's a freaking off it's just a terrible
tragedy so my goal is to inspire people
like look you got to get out of this
deal the government can't get you out
blame in China or India or whoever you
want to blame ok mommy daddy whoever you
want to blame is not going to change the
condition that's on this planet right
now if you want a better condition for
you and your family you got to figure
out you got to get extremely focused
you're gonna have to get 10x about it I
mean you're gonna have to demand it from
the universe you have to demand that
that this become like something that the
physical universe takes you serious
about like oh this guy's not kidding he
really wants this hey I was broke do you
understand
I was broke when I was 25 dead broke I'm
not talking about financially broke let
me tell you something no I didn't have
any money in my pocket I didn't have any
credit cards nobody would give me credit
okay didn't have a driver's license okay
1970 Ford Maverick had a 1970 Ford
Maverick no air no heat no door handles
the freakin floor was rusted okay I
lived in a 275 square foot apartment
maybe 300 square feet if he counted a
little step out in the front of the
front door Bay to 75 a month and I was
late almost every month so don't tell me
about your money problems man okay don't
tell me about where you were born don't
tell me about your bad brakes don't tell
me about what your daddy did or your
uncle felt you up or something did some
kind of weird thing to you no I'll ruin
your head or your sister abused you or
whatever okay look we all got problems
you got to fix your problems now you got
to get your money right so 25 years old
online I'm getting my money right I'm
done no more excuses no more crybaby no
more blame I'm getting my freaking money
right you want to get your work ethic so
high that people actually admire you I'm
gonna ask you a question right now do
people know you because of your
unbelievable work ethic if you can't
answer yes to that man you're not going
to get in that
10% you got to get at the top you people
have to know you
not because oh he's a good salesman oh
he's a good dish oh he's an artist so
he's a good pianist oh he's a he writes
a great you know story no did people
need to know you for one major thing
first he works he produces the guys
there every day the guys pushing and
shoving because the truth is no matter
how good your ideas are how good your
art is or how good your skill set is if
you're not working man if you're not
vibrating at a frequency that people say
my god how does that guy do all that if
you're not vibrating at that rate 10x
levels massive action tremendous work
ethic that's just a muscle nowness it's
just a discipline in your life and it's
a way it's a normal way that other
people think is abnormal Ryan Seacrest
Tom Cruise Oprah Steven Spielberg Donald
Trump still pumping and working as a
billionaire look if you're not working
at that level you're not gonna make it
get your work ethic young man it's the
American Way work ethic check it out
back to the 10x rule there are two
components to 10x in our lives which is
how we deal with all those challenges
that you just described we need a 10x
our thinking and we need the 10x our
action can you describe to us how do
what are some practical tips our
listeners can can engage let's say let's
say I'm a kid playing baseball yeah I
was I played baseball when I was until I
was in college and you see the problem
is the the reason I did I couldn't make
it is because I wasn't thinking about
big leagues
nobody told me to start if somebody
would have been telling me everyday do
big leagues your big league material
okay you could be in the big leagues
instead I was just thinking about
playing baseball and I love baseball
okay and I had little fantasies about
man maybe I could be a catcher in
professional football but I didn't have
anybody freaking like like covering me
up in this concept this think because I
didn't have a giant payoff I quit and
and the same thing is for money right if
you don't have a giant payoff in
business or economics if you're just
gonna get by you're gonna give up on the
deal because the think is not big enough
if you've ever noticed that people
appear your friends maybe they don't
appear
motivated and you're like dude where's
the motivation bro where when are you
gonna get excited what's happening with
you 70 some-odd percent of employees in
America are disengaged Wow because the
payoff the payoff is so small right
what's the payoff today I get a paycheck
I go to Whole Foods
I give them my paycheck I go home what's
the payoff in that dude it all I'm
reminded of is there's no payoff so
unless the individual the individual
needs to really understand unless the
payoff is gonna be enormous I'm going to
the moon bro
see I'd die to go to the moon okay I
don't want to die going to the grocery
store to get my last paycheck because
the payoff is big enough you get it so
first you got to change the thinking
once the thinking gets enormous enough
giant big giant think then you would
actually build a plan equivalent to hey
what would it take to become a
billionaire today I mean this is a
target that I have now so my fantasy now
is I'm gonna become a billionaire in
this lifetime and I'm gonna make it
public I'm gonna actually stream it out
it has never been done before and and
I'm gonna show the public how to become
a billionaire from where I'm at right
now to do that I need a huge giant
action plan that involves a lot of
failures a lot of misfires a lot of
starts but I didn't have the fuel to
finish a lot of mistakes are gonna
happen right and and then who knows man
maybe I get halfway there even if I get
halfway there the payoff is enormous see
most people think success is a straight
line I'm gonna get out of high school
I'm gonna get a job and everything's
gonna be fine that's not how it plays
out folks okay this how it plays out guy
decides he wants something and the line
gets all squiggly see right now a guy
decides over the summer hey man I'm
gonna go I'm gonna get this job this
summer and I'm gonna make some money
this summer and then he gets distracted
by the first squiggly I don't know what
he's doing he's squiggling off because
he's not focused on his success he
squiggles you ever used this term
squiggle yeah man I'm doing a squiggle
you know I'm gonna go out and hang out
with the guys this weekend it's a
squiggle
it's off path off purpose off potential
and so he ends up in a bunch of loops
over here most people get stuck in loops
I did it when I got out of high school I
was in a lot of trouble didn't have any
focus wasn't fulfilling my potential was
distracted didn't have a coach didn't
have an older brother didn't have a
father lost what am i doing
okay don't know where I'm going I know I
got this potential it's sitting there
inside of me it's a little candle
burning I know it's there I hadn't quite
put it out when I was twenty years old
but it was it was low any any of you
ever been there what am i doing every
day man why am I getting up every day
why am I going to school I didn't even
know why I was going to school I was
just going to school I was just doing
school I didn't even want to go to
school
see I'm squiggling around okay if you
persist and stay focus and surround
yourself with other people that persist
and stay focused
who knows maybe you'll come out the
other end today I spend 95% of my time
on offense financially on offense and 5%
or less sometimes sometimes actually on
defense what that means is this spend
all your time on banking money making
money spend money actually to make money
and only spend about 4 or 5 percent of
your times on budgets saving reducing
see the point here is this if you notice
how many people on this planet are
talking about saving money what they all
have in common what they all have in
common is a broke they're worried
they're scared they never have enough
money ok you know why because they're
spending ninety five percent of their
time on coupons clipping savings looking
for the best deal running all the way
across town to save a buck when they
could have spent all that time on Bank
and dough or making money on getting
creative and productive so look you can
start monetizing now you can start
making money now but you've got to get
your head right
that middle class mentality which really
is just a poor thing and start spending
all your time on building skills
investing money advertising marketing
promoting to do what you got to do to
get the income first the income
strengthen that first income flow then
start looking for symbiotic multiple
flows that are connected friendly flows
and then start banking money you save
money to invest that's the only reason
you save money now for retirement now
for problems in the future not for a
rainy day so that you can blow up and
explode with multiple passive income
flows into the future I just want people
to understand this you don't need to
love every second of every day okay you
don't need to love it you don't even
need to like it I mean I get sick I was
at the Pentagon talking to a bunch of
troops in transition and everybody was
up there the speakers were telling them
do what you love when you get back in
transition you've you've served us in
Afghanistan come back find what you love
and I'm like that's [ __ ] oh that's
crazy what are y'all doing man
you can look you need to do what it
takes whatever it takes to take care of
your family today most of what you and I
have to do every day
we don't love I mean I start my day like
this okay I start my day like man I
don't even know if I want to get up this
morning
dude I don't want to get up okay oh my
god Brian I don't want to get up today
dude I want to sleep in my little
six-year-old comes and jumps in she
plays I'm like I just want to stay in
here and just love on her all day but
you know what I'm like oh I got a drive
to work I got to show up and this is
where the flow happens when you push
through when you push through the grind
and like okay I'm gonna show up anyway
show up anyway and then all of a sudden
and this is where I agree I start
creating you know I start I start doing
my deal I start finding out who I really
am I started getting exercise my
creativity and then I'm like oh dude
that's what I'm here for but I'm in my
purpose now thank you guys so much for
watching I hope you
I'd love to know what did you take to
this video what are you going to
immediately apply somehow to your life
or to your business please leave your
thoughts down in the comments below I
look forward to hearing what you have to
say I also want to give a quick shout it
to Gary Coxe Gary thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word and doing the review on your
YouTube channel
I really really appreciate the support
man and I'm so glad you enjoyed the book
evans focusing on in his new book your
one word so thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love guys
I'll see you soon the most important
word ever if you had to think of one
word that's most important to you or
that sums you Apple that would be like a
little beacon hey believe nation if you
want to know what the most important one
word is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details
[Music]